Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today’s paper is about creating synthetic
human faces, and not only that, but it can
also make me look like Obi-Wan Kenobi.
You will see the rest of this footage in a
few minutes.
Now, of course, this is not the first paper
to generate artificial human faces.
For instance, in December of 2019 a technique
by the name StyleGAN2 was published.
This is a neural network-based learning algorithm
that is capable of synthesizing these eye-poppingly
detailed images of human beings that don’t
even exist.
This work answered some questions, and as
any good paper, raised many more good ones.
For instance, generating images of virtual
humans is fine, but what if the results are
not exactly what we are looking for?
Can we have some artistic control over the
outputs?
How do we even tell the AI what we are looking
for?
Well, we are in luck because StyleGAN2 offers
somewhat rudimentary control over the outputs
where we can give it input images of two people,
and fuse them together.
Now, that is absolutely amazing, but I wonder
if we can ask for a little more?
Can we get even more granular control over
these images?
What if we could just type in what we are
looking for, and somehow the AI would understand
and execute our wishes?
Is that possible, or, is that science fiction?
Well, hold on to your papers, and let’s
see.
This new technique works as follows.
We type what aspect of the input image we
wish to change, and what the change should
be.
Wow, really cool!
And we can even play with these sliders to
adjust the magnitude of the changes as well.
This means that we can give someone a new
hairstyle, add or remove makeup, or give them
some wrinkles for good measure.
Now, the original StyleGAN2 method worked
on not only humans, but on a multitude of
different classes too.
And the new technique also inherits this property,
look.
We can even design new car shapes, make them
a little sportier, or make our adorable cat
even cuter.
For some definition of cuter, of course.
We can even make their hair longer
or change their colors, and the results are
of super high quality.
Absolutely stunning.
While we are enjoying some more results here,
make sure to have a look at the paper in the
video description, and if you do, you will
find that we really just scratched the surface
here, for instance, it can even add clouds
to the background of an image, or redesign
the architecture of buildings, and much, much
more.
There are also comparisons against previous
methods in there, showcasing the improvements
of the new method.
And now, let’s experiment a little on me.
Look, this is me here, after I got locked
up for dropping my papers.
And I spent so long in there, that I grew
a beard.
Or I mean, a previous learning-based AI called
StyleFlow gave me one.
And since the dropping your papers is a serious
crime, the sentence is long…quite long.
Ouch.
I hereby promise to never drop my papers,
ever again.
So now, let’s try to move forward with this
image, and give it to this new algorithm for
some additional work.
This is the original.
And by original I mean image with the added
algorithmic beard from a previous AI.
And this is the embedded version of the image.
This image looks a little different.
Why is that?
It is because StyleGAN2 runs an embedding
operation on the photo before starting its
work.
This is its own internal understanding of
my image if you will.
This is great information, and is something
that we can only experience if we have hands-on
experience with the algorithm.
And now, let’s use this new technique to
apply some more magic to this image.
This is where the goodness happens.
And, oh my, it does not disappoint!
You see, it can gradually transform me into
Obi-Wan Kenobi.
An elegant algorithm, for a more civilized
age.
But that’s not all.
It can also create a ginger Károly, hippie
Károly, Károly who found a shiny new paper
on fluid simulations, and Károly who read
said paper outside for quite a while, and
was perhaps disappointed.
And now, hold on to your papers and please
welcome Dr. Karolina Zsolnai-Fehér.
And one more, I apologize in advance…rockstar
Károly, with a mohawk.
How cool is that?
I would like to send a huge thank you to the
authors for taking time out of their workday
to create these images only for us, you can
really only see these here on Two Minute Papers.
And as you see, the pace of progress in machine
learning research is absolutely stunning,
and with this, the limit of our artistic workflow
is going to be not our mechanical skills,
but only our imagination.
What
a time to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!